and I thought Polston was a wise guy
when he called me this morning about
wearing blue with white stars will you
begin Margo yes
the nominees for the best achievement
and sound are Arthur PN FET pianted you
see less fresh holds Richard Tyler and
Al Overton jr. for bite the bullet
Richard Portman Don MacDougall curly
thir well and Jack Solomon for funny
lady
Leonard Petersen John a Bolger jr. John
Mac and Don K Sharples for the
Hindenburg Robert L Hoyt Roger Heymann
Earl Madhuri John Carter for Jaws Harry
W Tetrick Aaron Rasheen William McCoy
and Roy Sharman for the wind and the
lion and the winner is
Robert el Hoyt Roger he mineral matter a
and John Carter to draw
well I really don't know what to say
except uh I thank everybody very much
and yeah that's all I can really say
thank you
I can only echo mr. Hoyt sediments it's
a great honor thank you very much
I'd like to thank the sound branch
executive committee who promoted and the
Academy Board who voted this Oscar
because it is extended to the sound
effects mixer for the first time this
honor and I also had liked to include
the sound effects editors at Universal
who provided my material and made my
contribution possible I would like to
thank John McDonald and Bill Griffith
and all the rest of them that
contributed so much fart thank you very
much
you